hat das gold schwert die funktionen
eines bogens das heißt ich kann hier
rechts gedrückt und kam mit dem mit dem
schwert kann ich dann einfach pfeile
schießen alle meine lieben freunde
herzlich willkommen
mir wurden wieder extrem cool effect
zugesendet ich habe mir fünf konfekt
rausgesucht und ich würde auf jeden fall
bis zum ende dran bleiben weil
ja weil ich mir mit dem video gebe und
jedenfalls würde ich direkt wieder das
typische dings am anfang sagen das ist
total komisch wenn ich das hier so den
kreis drehen
ich war beim friseur ich glaube das
sieht man
ich bin sehr sehr zufrieden irgendwie
können die friseure hier in hamburg
können das irgendwie viel viel besser
als die damals wo ich damals gewohnt
haben findet ihr da schreibt jetzt mal
in die kommentare ich habe hier sieben
millimeter amran das ist zwar schon
relativ kurz aber ich mag es irgendwie
ich würde einfach wieder sagen ich kann
nicht dafür garantieren dass er nicht
schon alle sachen kennen die ich hier
vorstelle und wir fangen direkt am 1 es
wurde mir zugesendet von luis trenker
bvb unterschreibt und ich habe effekt
für dich wo ich mir nicht sicher bin ob
es ihnen schon gar wenn man aus der
fällt fällt welt der welt hätte und man
in die f5 ansicht geht und dann von
unten kann man sich sehen also das ist
ein bisschen komisch beschrieben ich
zeige euch das mal so und zwar hier ist
der letzte block ich jetzt raus ihr seht
schon f3 oder ich muss es gar nicht mehr
freizeit man sieht hier schon ist die
komplette welt hier das ganze wird nicht
richtig gerendert dann muss man immer
mit ob die firma ganz kurz ran zoomen
jedenfalls sieht so die welt von unten
aus und wenn ich jetzt einfach mal f5
drücken seht ihr schon von der seite
sehe ich mich so wenn ich jetzt aber
eher nach oben gucken bin ich für kurze
zeit weg
hier sehe ich mich wieder wenn ich jetzt
auf einer höhe bis nach oben bin ich weg
jetzt sehe ich mich wieder ganz kurz
wenn ich weiter nach oben gucken
moment moment moment das ist auf einer
ebene die ok ich bin jetzt nicht so weit
unten wenn ich jetzt müssen nach unten
gehe hier ist das nämlich so wenn ich
bitten wir darum gehe wieder wenn ich
nach oben fliege hier kann ich mich so
sehen
hier bin ich mich kurz nicht ansehen
wenn ich weiter nach unten gehe kann ich
mich hier gar nicht sehen wenn ich mich
um guckt nur von unten bis zu der höhe
wenn ich noch weiter nach unten gehen
kann ich mich nur noch hier mal sehen
und wenn ich hier bin ist das ganze
wo bin ich wo man ihr nicht hier bin ist
das ganze mehr oder weniger verpackten
und zwar kann ich mich bis hierhin sehen
dann bin ich ab hier wieder weg dann bin
ich hier kurz wieder da und jetzt bin
ich wieder weg also ich weiß nicht woran
das liegt das ist hier kurz geht hier
geht's dann wieder nicht eventuell
kommen wieder einige annahmen das ist
ein entity und deswegen geht so und so
nicht aber das ist auf jeden fall fact
nummer eins ist ein bisschen eine
komische sache dann kann dich check-up
evb lu ist reiner luft mehr bekommen und
zwar richtig doof ist auch im
hintergrund steht gerade pizza bei mir
offen das heißt ich muss eigentlich
richtig durchziehen das video ihr ziel
zu bringen
2 wurde mir zugesendet von paul und zwar
meint er dass höhe 255 kann man zwar
keinen block mehr drauf setzen
allerdings einen schalter und einen
anderen button das zeige ich euch
allerdings gleich wenn wir da oben sind
dass ich euch erstmal zeigen wollte war
ganz einfach ich habe jedes maxtax
spektren und habe meine welt hier wieder
so ein bisschen mein ab mäßig gemacht
das heißt in den nächsten folgen wäre
die sonne das ganze ist ein bisschen
weihnacht nicht kreiert ihr seht schon
hier sind ein paar skins am start von
unter anderem blumen monkey dann haben
wir hier so ein kleines spielzeug dings
hier haben wir ein teddybär da haben wir
so in wieder einen spielzeug links hier
vorne hatte ich irgendwo noch ein stuhl
hingestellt das ist einfach mit dem text
ein bisschen kreiert das heißt für die
nächsten folgen werden wir immer diese
welt dann benutzen und da leuchtturm
penis keine ahnung ich baue gerade nach
oben und sieht dass hier von hier oben
extrem cool aus da unten ist unsere welt
hier so alles voll so mit schnee und eis
und alles das macht mir irgendwie macht
mir richtig winter feeling so ein
bisschen ich habe richtig lust auf
schnee dieses jahres war es halt immer
so du musst mit dem fahrrad zur schule
fahren das nicht so geil mit schnee und
so aber dieses jahr ist echt irgendwie
weiß nicht ob es werden sehr viel lust
darauf so freunde ihr seht schon links
am rand dabei xyz ist die mittlere zahl
jetzt bei 255 und ihr seht schon wenn
ich hier versuche einstein draufzusetzen
es geht also ich stelle mich jetzt mal
einfach hierhin ihr seht bei der höhe
ich bin meiner 255 das sehe denke ich
und hier kann ich keinen steinen
draufsetzen da kommt allerdings im chat
keine meldungen wenn ich mir allerdings
irgendwie einen hebel hole oder auch ich
könnte man knopf holen und dann setze
ich beispielsweise mal setzte ich hier
einen schalter hin und hier setze ich
ein knopf hin
dann kann ich die halter darauf setzen
allerdings wenn ich jetzt hier versuchen
noch einen blog drauf zu setzen oder den
schalter drücken kann ich natürlich aber
wenn ich jetzt hier beispielsweise den
schalter hebel oder hier jetzt mal ein
knopfdruck da kommt ja immer noch eine
neue meldung ich kann ihr keinen knopf
draufsetzen da kommt immer diese meldung
die maximale bauhöhe beträgt 256 blöcke
da frage ich mich natürlich wenn ich
hier etwas draufsetzen oder wenn ich
hier den schalter drücken dann kommt die
meldung wenn ich allerdings nie etwas
drauf setzte dann kommt das nicht ihr
seht schon im chat da kommt keine
weitere meldung wenn ich hier allerdings
was drauf setzte kommt da diese weitere
meldung also ich weiß nicht was das soll
eventuell könnt ihr mir erklären mal
wieder mit der entity formulierung hier
immer ankommen bei wein fekter endlich
was zu tun aber das ist auf jeden fall
fake nummer zwei das die maximale
bauhöhe so ein bisschen komisch ist und
es hat mir zugesagt von paul und danke
an dich paulus konfekt nummer drei
befreundet wir sind wieder hinten den
themen und fächer irgendwie sie das
schon
ich weiß nicht ich finde es sieht ganz
gut aus mit diesen teddybären und
geschenken und mit dem eis und so ich
weiß was haltet ihr davon was kann ich
an dieser welt noch verbessern also die
wird dann natürlich nur bis zum 24 oder
irgendwie so mal schauen wie lange ich
ja oder kompletten dezember jedenfalls
wurde mit effekte von rudis 4 findet ihr
eigentlich dass ich zu schnell rede
immer also ich war letztens bei seinem
meeting irgendwie von der deutschen bahn
war das glaube ich und die meinten dass
sich extrem schnell rede
aber das ist halt irgendwie so meine art
dass ich schnell rede aber wenn ihr sagt
dass er da nicht hinterherkommt dann
schreibt mir das mal bitte jeden fall
schreibt mir der release 4 dass ich hier
einfach mal rein tun sollen und jetzt
ganz normal wenn ich auf dem blog stehe
und ich gehe hoch und ich lass mich
fallen seht ihr ja schon da kommen diese
schnee partikel wenn ich hier auf diesem
blog bin und ich fliege hoch und geh
runter kommen diese geschenkartikel
partikel nicht geschenkartikel was ist
denn wenn ich auf dieses ding drauf
ankommen okay da kommt da kommt
wahrscheinlich einfach nur weil an
diesem tag speck ist dieser blog hier
ein
redstone kommt ihr adsense monrose oder
ja das konnte roter sandstein sondern
ebenfalls ist es hier so bin ich in lava
falle ganz normal seht ihr schon momente
aber taktisch falsch gesehen und zwar
wenn ich hier so hoch bin und ich gehe
in die lava sie schon da kommen keine
partikel wenn ich allerdings viermal so
lang fliegen und nicht lang fliegen
sondern runs nico und ich es nie für
mich hier so hin bei der lava red ist
allerdings so ihr seht schon ich bin
hier in lava fliegt ein bisschen hoch
lasst mich runter fallen die lava und
fall einfach in die lava rein
also man kriegt quasi die partikel wenn
man wirklich auf den block drauf fällt
nur wenn ich mal einfach so weg gibt es
sich hier nicht mehr weiterfliegen kann
also ihr seht schon ich stehe hier schon
nahezu wirklich in der lage hier mit
meinem tollen weihnachts gehen meine ich
bin auf jeden fall so weit weg wie es
geht und jetzt fliege ich mal hoch im
creative und wenn ich jetzt runter falle
lande ich ja auf diesem schnee blog
allerdings achtet man auch die partikel
da kommen lava partikel als würde ich
auf die lava darauf fallen obwohl ich
eigentlich auf diesen schnee blog drauf
falle also ich lasse mich noch mal
fallen da kommen lava partikel ich weiß
sie wollen das liegt wenn ich auf den
schnee blockiert kommen natürlich die
schnee partikel aber wenn ich so weiß
nicht wie es geht
ich fliege hoch und lass mich runter
fallen dann kommen die läufer partikel
als wenn ich schon in diesem blog drin
wäre
bis jetzt bin ich sogar den block 3 also
dass aspect nummer drei und danke an die
credit suisse 4 radieschen vier keine 80
die nächste sache wurde mir zugesichert
von klappert es ist mit interessant ist
den namen mit dem ihr irgendwas zu
gesendet wurde und zwar hole ich mir
jetzt diese sachen hier einfach mal und
zwar hab ich im beispielsweise ein
schwert auf der stelle sieben dann einen
bogen auf der eins und die pfeile
brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht
jedenfalls habe ich euch ja gezeigt wie
man ein schwert schneller auf eine
andere position kriegen kann indem man
einfach hier drückt und dann hier
einfach jetzt zwei drückt oder vier oder
irgendwie sowas und es ist auch möglich
wenn ich das schwert beispielsweise hier
auf die einst packe dass ich dann auch
in creative blöcke zerstören kann mit
dem schwert jetzt muss ich das natürlich
wieder aufbauen allerdings hat mir der
klub adapter oder die klappe dabei ich
weiß es nicht ganz genau zugesendet dass
wenn ich mir beispielsweise einen
goldstadt mit der einst mit dem bogen
austausche hat das gold schwert die
funktionen eines bogens das heißt ich
kann hier rechtsklick gedrückt hat und
kam mit dem mit dem schwert kann ich
dann einfach pfeile schießen das geht
sogar so also ich kann einfach nur kurz
mal drücken dann kommt so ein kleiner
pfeil und wenn ich länger gedrückt halte
dann kommt schon etwas besser
geschossenes dingsbums und auch wenn ich
mir irgendwie mal hier ein
pole zum beispiel einfach mal ein
kleines schwein ja so jetzt hab ich
jetzt zwei schweine am start wenn ich
kann natürlich dazu mal hier mit dem
bogen abschießen
ich kann aber auch einfach mal ein
schwert nehmen und einfach mal so
schießen ob sie so muss das wieder
umtauschen ich hab den bogen kurz
verwendet und lebt jetzt hier wieder
einst und jetzt hat der rat das schwert
diese fähigkeiten und jetzt kann ich
hier mit einfach diese schweine hier
abschießen auf eine bestimmte
schnelligkeit ihr wisst ich bin nicht so
der beste minecraft schütze und da sie
die beiden scheint es ganz interessant
man kann quasi das schwert dadurch im
creative zum bogen machen wenn man
danach den bogen ich benutze also wenn
ich jetzt hier beispielsweise man viel
schießt dann kann ich mit dem schwert
hier auch doch kann ich doch noch machen
ok krass das funktioniert es doch dann
weiß nicht woran das gelegen hat aber
dann will ich auf jeden fall sagen meine
lieben freunde das war feck nummer vier
und ich wollte gerade die enhk art
machen aber jetzt kommt noch fact nummer
finden wollen ihr seht schon wieder ein
bild eingeblendet und zwar wurde mir
dieser effekt zugesendet von sebastian
und zwar hat er sich dass minecraft
mojang buch für minecraft beginner
gekauft und zwar lese ich euch jetzt
einfach mal vor was da steht und zwar
unter schon gewusst auch dorfbewohner
können sich vermehren und der zeugen
süße dorfbewohner bei wie sie vermehren
sich ganz von selbst und jetzt kann das
interessante bis ihre zahl etwa 35
prozent der im dorf war an den türen
entspricht wenn du also die anzahl der
bewohner erhöhen willst ergänzte ein
paar türen also wie es eventuell wyss
dorfbewohner kann man nicht einfach so
vermehren indem man weizen auf die drauf
klickt oder so man das beispielsweise
bei irgendwelchen kühen macht wo man die
mit weizen twitter oder bei hühnern wie
man wenn man den namen gibt und dann
kommen die aufeinander zu und dann
fahren die sich das geht bei
dorfbewohnern nicht ich bin ja selber
ein dorfbewohner ich weiß ich kann mir
selber buchen weniger als frau mit denn
jedenfalls wusste ich diesen effekt echt
nicht und das ist mir richtig richtig
cool dass e mails zugesendet hat wenn
ihr solche effekte die sind echt mega
interessant die finde ich richtig cool
dann schickt mir die einfach per mail an
kontrakte gmail.com jedenfalls besagt
dieser effekt dass wenn ihr
beispielsweise in einem dorf seit und
vermehren sich die dorfbewohner die
ganze zeit und irgendwann denken sich
die wir wollen keine anderen
dorfbewohner mehr
dann müsst ihr einfach mit ihr noch mehr
ab wollt dann müsst ihr einfach mehr
türen platzieren in diesem dorf einfach
daran denken die soja wir haben mehr
türen das heißt mehr häuser blabla wir
brauchen nachwuchs so nach dem motto und
damit kann man die mehr oder weniger
anhalt vermehren ich sagte so oft mehr
oder weniger das war auf jeden fall ein
richtig cooler effekt der mir dazu
gesendet wurde noch von sebastian hier
ende und ich will einfach sagen meine
lieben freunde wenn euch die folge
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen und schreib mir cool
effect und crafter gmail.com und dann
sehen wir uns in einer nächsten folge
wie der times